hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from the chessable Masters
playing it is a Quang Liam Le versus
Maxim chigaive and it's a brutal game
where only two uh Bishops uh or rather a
set of Bishops and a set of Pawns leave
the board and the final position is all
the pieces are still on the board but uh
one of the players cannot move a single
piece as you've seen from the thumbnail
uh it's a really wild one only 31 move
uh let's check it out uh
opens with Pawn to D4 and we will have
another King's Indian defense Knight to
F6 C for G6 Knight the C3 and Bishop to
G7 we have the king's Indian defense E4
uh we have D6 and not Knight Gita e to
the Kramer variation of the king's
Indian Ponte E5 and now Pawn to D5 and
now there are a couple of moves that
were played in this position but here we
have Ponte H5 and it is now already as
of move six that we have a completely
new game and the wife replies with Ponte
H4 of course you don't uh probably
seeing this for the first time you don't
want to allow black the even the option
of uh playing H4 at any point so Pawn to
H4 uh we have pawned the A5 very nice uh
expanding on both sides of the board and
now Knight to G3 in the olden days this
would be frowned upon but nowadays uh
it's 2023 we have engines so we can play
pretty much anything uh Knight to A6
with Bishop to E2 and now Bishop to D7
so both players just nicely developing
pieces Bishop to G5 Bishop to H6 and now
Bishop captures on H6 we have Rook
captures and now Queen to D2 going after
the rook and The Rook goes back and now
that the Bishops have left the board
those are the only pieces that will be
exchanged uh we have Queen side Castles
by uh Le and now Queen to E7 preparing
castles Queen side as well King the B1
and now Knight to C5 first there's
always time at the castle as you'll see
in this game and you've played A5 so you
don't have to worry about B for this
lodging the knight from C5 we have Pawn
to F3 as the four Pawn is also being
pressured uh Pawn to B6 and now Knight
the F1 remanuvering the Knight over to
E3 we have Queen to f8 going for H6
hoping to trade off queens and now
Knight to E3 Queen to H6 and um and now
Rook D to F1 uh you might have some
ideas of f4 maybe G4 in the future
Knights the G8 preparing F5 and now Pawn
to G4 stopping F5 we have Queen to F4 uh
and now Bishop to D3 and this is um
a very classy move and truly a uh just a
remarkable remarkable move uh the
problem is you cannot capture with uh
Bishop with Knight characters Bishop uh
and with the bishop on D3 and at some
point of course the best will come to
see too soon you you will no longer have
to worry about that but you are still
preventing that pawn to a F5
breakthrough which black is really
looking forward to and the problem uh
with Knight captures on D3 is a very
tricky one and uh even uh calls for a
pause the video moment so feel free to
pause the video and try to figure out
what's wrong with Knight captures and D3
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh incredible idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Pawn to G5 this traps The Black Queen on
F4 now you control F5 G6 F5 F6 and also
uh Pawn is controlling the the G4 square
and there's no good defense against
Knight the E2 which will trap the black
queen and notice that if you play
something like Knight to C5 let's say we
attack the queen with Knight to the E2
Knight captures an E4 attacks the White
Queen as well and now you're hoping for
captures and captures but the white just
plays Queen to C1 and now the black
queen has no squares and black really
doesn't have a way of uh dealing with
this and it doesn't even help if after
G5 you claim the G3 square right away
saying that maybe I can escape from here
again Knight they do covers uh F4 and
the G3 so yeah you are again dead lost
here so that's the reason why Knight
captures on D3 is impossible and
congratulations to everyone who spotted
this G5 idea it's not an easy move to
spot you know because okay you want to
capture back but you know it's probably
not that so you look for something else
but still G5 is a very nice idea so here
Queen back to H6 now again G5 is
possible right away but first Bishop to
C2 we don't want to worry about this
tension um uh anymore uh in this game
Knight to E7 and now Pawn to G5 Queen G7
and pawn to F for now now uh with the
backwards F7 Pawn white is looking
forward to opening up the f file
doubling up or maybe even tripling up on
the file and going after that F7 Pawn as
that truly is a weakness so e captures
on F4 Rook capture is now Queen to E5
attacks The Rook but just Knight to F5
even though you could consider a move
like Rook H to F1 and uh you know
there's no shame in Rook H to F1 it's
it's a fine move but Knight to F5 is
truly a classy move Now The Rook is
nicely defended and you can't capture
the Knight if you capture the Knight
then look at this e captures on F5 and
what do you what do you play next The
Rook the E1 is coming whatever you play
if you trade Bishop captures uh then
just Bishop captures on F5 and of course
if Knight captures then Rook D1 wins the
queen and if you don't capture you could
of course just Castle Queen side uh not
not better
uh rookie one attacks the queen and once
the queen moves G7 is your only Square
uh F6 is coming and black just falls
apart a king queen goes to Gita we're
gonna capture on E7 threaten The Rook
after rookie 8 Rook F6 and uh you've
completely paralyzed the blacks uh uh
pieces the the bishop has no useful
moves the knight uh also no useful moves
The Rook Queen and Rook uh can't even
move so I mean it's a terrible terrible
position uh so after this Knight to F5
move uh Rook the f8 was played but it
doesn't help now the Knight gets
re-maneuvered to an even more powerful
Square Knight to D4 with Bishop to G4
and now Rook H to F1 doubling up on the
on the f file uh probably your best
option is just the castle and part with
the F7 Pawn because defending it will
not lead to anything good but even this
would be I would be lost for black
because that's a really important Pawn
that's the base of the pawn chain and
then everything just crumbles so Knights
the D7 was played and now comes Bishop
to A4 pinning the Knight and here okay
now you really I have to Castle there's
no more waiting around uh but in the
game Bishop to H3 was played attacking
The Rook rooked Rook one to F3 Bishop
attacks The Rook once again Rook to F2
and now even Queen to G7 uh but now uh
Liam finishes off with a beautiful
beautiful uh move and that is Knight to
the E6 and he was in this position I
moved 31 that Maxim shigaya resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here as you can see everything is
hanging the queen is hanging The Rook is
hanging Knight the C7 check is in the
air uh there's uh there's no move you
can play the obvious one F captures an
E6 doesn't work because just Rook
captures an f8 and the Knight like we
said cannot move you're gonna have to
capture with the queen and now once the
king captures you're even gonna pick up
the Knight on D7 and you are just up uh
you have a queen for a rook of course uh
completely winning for white and other
than that you really don't have a move I
mean you you could move the queen but
then Knight captures on C7 check picks
up the rook and um it's just a
completely unplayable so uh uh Chicago
uh messed up somewhere he uh really got
tied up in all of this uh but it's it's
wonderful that uh like I said only a
pair of Pawns and a pair of Bishops got
traded off the board and uh well it's a
very very rare that you will have a
position like this uh in modern chess in
2023 against two very very strong Grand
Masters uh so yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you have any
other favorites from chessable Masters
playing do you use hashtag suggestion
and I will go over it uh where uh now uh
ready for the main event I would like to
thank Ryan Kavanaugh uh uh Bob roboshov
uh Anonymous happy 33 and lost one for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing uh the
coverage of everything that's happening
in the Chess World and you know checking
up on your suggest questions as usual so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day